give you heard of q q is the most
dastardly awful terrible conspiracy
theory in the whole wide world it's so
bad the Twitter is going to start
banning accounts that talk about it talk
about that thing that I don't really
know very much about Twitter tweets out
yesterday's from Twitter safety the
committee for safety if you've got to
watch out you're in danger because you
might read words that you don't like
we've been clear that we will take a
strong enforcement action on behavior
that has the potential to lead to
offline harm in line with this approach
this week we are taking further action
on so-called Q anon activity across this
service Q and on I don't know very much
about Q and on we get some questions
about it sometimes but I haven't looked
into it particularly deeply but from
what I gather from the Twitter safety
tweet this is a very dangerous
conspiracy theory very dangerous
conspiracy theory that is percolating on
the right and so they've got to shut
down any account that's in any way
associated with it
but I notice Twitter safety doesn't care
that much about dangerous conspiracy
theories percolating on the left that
lead to offline harm for instance there
is a conspiracy theory out there held on
the left by you know kind of kooky
people on the left that black people are
the real Jews and the Jews are the fake
Jews you would have seen this conspiracy
theory just in the last week because
Nick Cannon very famously endorsed this
theory louis farrakhan who is a hate
monger who's still on twitter by the way
these people have promoted this idea
sometimes you see people on street
corners talking about it but you've seen
a lot of people on Twitter talking about
it then actually when Nick Cannon was
forced to make an apology a lot of the
responses to that tweet said come on
stand up you add the truth tell the
truth so that's also a conspiracy theory
by the way that has led to violence in
the real world we know for a fact that's
led to outside harm Twitter doesn't care
about that one here's another conspiracy
theory on the Left racist cops are
systematically slaughtering black men
across the country innocent black men
it's not happening we went through the
numbers of
unarmed black men last year who were
killed by police officers and by the way
don't forget unarmed does not mean not
dangerous does not mean that the killing
was not justified but the number is not
90,000 not 900 not 90 it's nine nine so
that is a ridiculous conspiracy theory
and now cops are being killed because of
that conspiracy theory all around the
country Twitter encouraging that pushing
it on using the hashtag black lives
matter which is used to organize those
kind of violent riots by self-avowed
trained Marxists and then the third
conspiracy theory that was allowed to
percolate and still is that Donald Trump
the man we've known for 40 years is
actually a Manchurian Candidate a stooge
for Russia that's the most ridiculous
conspiracy theory of all that one was
pushed by the DOJ the FBI big tech the
mainstream media every mainstream
publication it's still being pushed even
though we now know for a fact it didn't
happen because we had a two and a half
year multi multi-million dollar
investigation from bob miller came up
with zilch what about those can i think
those conspiracy theories in particular
the russia one have had a far greater
outsized impact on the real world then
some tweets about q don't you think i
think so and yet twitter everybody's
only targeting those right-wing
conspiracies this idea of the conspiracy
theory though is just throw it on the
right the left has many crazy conspiracy
theories
they've many crazy theories in general
they think men can be women and they
think babies aren't babies but they're
not treated in the same way and even
that category that idea of going after
the conspiracy theory is a way to push
cockamamie left-wing theories and
suppress right-wing theories i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description or download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you
[Music]